Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Oxygen Not Included.
Now.. yeah, I didn't stop.
I COULDN'T stop.
I literally COULD NOT walk away from this knowing what happened the last
the last group of people that I was with!
It was HEARTBREAKING evr- seeing every one of those people
that I have been watching since the beginning
and trying to help, and I came so close...
I came so far- I learned so much and I came so close
and I JUST... didn't get there..
I was THAT close.
Eh, probably not, I was probably miles away, I probably-
They probably would've died for another reason if it wasn't going to be food.
but it just... ugh, couldn't leave it at that.
So, what I'm gonna do...
is I'm comin' back into it! I'm gonna start a new one
And I am gonna go for this.
Because I am READY
So what I want..
I don't want anyone who is a DESTRUCTIVE ASSHOLE.
I want VOMITERS.
Because at least VOMITING doesn't break your shit.
So I'm gonna pay attention to that.
*sigh*
Alright, this is good. Nah, I can do better than that.
Uhh, gastrophobia, can't cook.. nah, we can do better.
Scaredy cat? Can't fight? That's okay.
Night owl? uhh.. nah.
The Not-So-Underground Fortress, Starving Spacepad...
Ugh!! That strikes a chord with me!
The Starving Spacepad will be the most food-abundant spacepad
in the ENTIRE UNIVERSE.
(i dont even know where this is in relation to the entire universe)
BUT I'M HOPING
that it's going to be okay.
Alright
So, first off, new hope. Yeah, you got a new hope alright.
"Your crew has awoken"- bzhzhb ble trh sz ble (Mark mocking the on-screen dialogue)
"best to start digging" Oh yeah it is.
Okay, so everybody just hold onto your horses here.
Because I'm gonna go through this very methodically
So as we see above us, we got Oxylite
Uh, which is providing a lot of oxygen, obviously
So we're gonna keep that around
We've got water right there,  we've got VERY adjacent water sources, that's actually quite good
Mealwood there, which is fine
Alright
So the first step of what we're doing- we already have food
I don't need to worry about that for a good long time
So, what we're gonna do is I'm gonna dig over to here
Hmm
Nah, I'm not gonna quite break that wall just yet
But I know we can dig that high
And then we're gonna bring it to this wall here
Just in case it decides to break on us
Alright! Go for it!
When you don't have too many problems, things seem to go a little easier for you
Oh yeah
Oh, now we're getting it
Aww man, I gotta research everything all over again
That was one of the benefits was that I got all my research out of the way first
Ah, before, but
This time
This time, I'm gonna go
I'm gonna do it
Gonna do it right
Gonna do it well
Oh, things run so smoothly now
(Mark laughs) This is lovely
I can't believe it
I can hardly believe it.
Ohh no!
Nails is stressed!
Oh, what are we gonna do about that?!
Oh no! Stress! Not that!
Okay.
The other thing that it was a problem in the last game that I did is that I built too much.
And too much, is uh... is uh... just as bad as not enough.
In my opinion anyway
Oh good! Three beds right there. That'll be perfect!
Boinkedy, boinkedy, boinkedy.
Perfect.
Ahhhhh, you just shit yourself. Goddammit!
We just frickin' did this shit!
Research station come oooooon!
Come onnnnn!
Ooh we're about to get our next duplicant!
So the benefit of, um, what we have here is actually there are
Mealwood plants up here
It's nice and cool up there, it works out well.
They're doing their thing.
Everything is good.
But we will need to worry about oxygen very soon
So I'm gonna need them to dig out basically this stuff here.
And then I'm gonna put a hold on this stuff because we don't need it immediately
This is not an express concern of ours
So, we're gonna have this one
We got "research farming tech". That's what we're gonna need.
We're gonna need farming tech most definitely.
And then everything else can wait until we got farming tech underway.
So once that gets powered, which it is now
We're gonna have this just generatin' all this research out the wazoo
Until we're good to go
So, this is fine
You see how planning makes things go much easier?
Wouldn't- who- who'd thunk it?
Man, this is craaaazy
Oh man, coordination = cooperation = looooove
I love it
Uh-oh, woah, what the hell? Goddammit
How did that bury through- that many-
Oh you gotta be kidding me
Oh COME ON!
Oh Jeezus
Of course, if it's not one thing, it's another thing,
Well (hah!) I guess there goes my water
(softly) Goddammit
Fucking... son-of-a-bitch, are you joking?
Thank you
Goddammit
Of course
Oh God, they're all flooded now
Frickin' wonderful
Frickin', frickin' wonderful
If it's not one thing, it's another
(softly) Goddammit
Alright, any day now on those Microbe Crushers (*Mushers)
That'd be nice, okay
They're gonna eat (x3), they're gonna eat a whole lot
We'll get the Algae Terrariums going their way, which is good, totally fine
They're gonna use some water, that's, again, totally fine
And then eventually, we'll just need to focus on getting more
Alright, so we now have these, so we're going to use these to make
Lice Loaf, only
That way, we don't have anyone doing a Mushbar, and they're not getting very
Ya know
Sick
So now that we got that, I'm gonna hold off on the research for now, because I need to make
I need to make
A refinement thing, which is a composter, riiiiiiiight here cause we're gonna need that
Yeah, cause we can't just have contaminated dirt sticking around cause that's gonna be bad for everybody
Let's make this a priority build
Okay, so now that this is open here, we can puuuut
some farming tech here, some planter boxes
Just a whooooole boatload of them
We're not gonna run outta food THIS time
Oh no-oo-oo, not today
(Deep Mark) Not toda-aa-ay
Not today, we're gonna...
Put these there, we're gonna get this
Just unbelievable amount of Mealwood
Okay, so far so good, everything seems to be looking up
There is a Puft right over here that, uh, is in...
A nice, sustainable place, so if I can seal that off
Keep that Puff doing what that Puff does
I'll create a double airlock so absolutely no contaminated, uh...
Oxygen gets in our way
And then, uh...
Should be good
OHH, we got a new person? COME ON IN!
Alright
Oh, all of of them are destructive, good.
Gonna always get destructive.
M'Kay. Irritable Bowe..
uhhhhhhhhh euhhhhhh
Vernon, Gus...
Sybil..
Eh, enough farters. Let's get Vernon
in here, he doesn't need much to be satisfied.
Come on Vernon, we go work to dooo!
....and preferably not death to do.
Looks like this actually might be producing some contaminated oxygen.
Which I didn't think it was actually doing,
but it seems like it is.
So i'm not gonna let that get to me.
That's definitely not gonna happen.
no no no, not today..
not today.
So I gotta really think about this.
I've got to really, really think about the layout.
Because what i've created here, is..
a place where..
every gas can flow between one and the other.
So contaminated oxygen is going to affect everything around it.
I don't think these terrariums are gonna be enough
to get through.
But they use so little,
Like, little. (yes mark, little equals little.)
They use so little algae.
But the problem is, I don't know if it's, like, this just does it faster or what.
Yeah, this uses ten..
This uses a kilogram of algae per second.
Okay, so that's not a equivalent exchange. The better option is
algae terrariums.
Like, that's just is what it is.
I'll move them if need be
I just like.. because that's a one-to-one ratio.
It consumes one gram of algae per second.
to emit a certain amount of oxygen
per second
Sometimes more than the gram of algae.
but the algae deoxidizer,
takes more algae than it puts out
oxygen.
So there's not reason to use that.
In my opinion, right now.
maybe in the future, yes, but in my opinion right now,
I think it's more beneficial to use the algae terrariums.
and just have more of em'.
Now, the problem is they will use water.
and water is a finite resource.
and it does use quite a bit of water.
(silence)
So there's that exchange.
It's really fascinating how it's so hard to find
A point of equilibrium in this game
Like, you're always pushing to do, like, a little more
You HAVE to keep going or else YOU'RE GONNA  DIE
Like, that's always a constant threat in this game
And I really like the challenge because
You can never just sit and go like
"Ok, I've got this, this is all good, this is good, I like this"
"We're all done here and I'm happy"
That's not the way it goes
You just constantly, always are pushing a little harder
Because they're always consuming oxygen
They're always consuming food
They're always dying for one reason or another
They're always stressed for one reason or another
So...
We'll get there though
We will get there
So, what I need to do is I need to start planning my...
filtration stuff
'Cause the research is almost done on the super computer
It'll be there probably before the end of today
Then I need to start building the two stage...
Uh, filtration center for like the dump of all the...
The...
The dump for the other stuff and then
You know, yadda yadda yadda
Ok, stress is down! Stress is at zero!
Yes! We're keeping stress down. Ok, that's good.
So, we've got tons and tons of algae
All over the place
And oxylite, but that's not really a big deal
We've gotta good bit of oxygen up there
Oh! Wha-? Ah, Vernon! Goddamnit! Mop that up!
Damn it, Vernon! The bathroom is right there-
Oh, it needs to be... Oops
Oopsieees! Oopsie poopsies indeed!
Ok, so, I've got the liquid stu- OOHHHH
We've got harvest time, baby!
Oh, we've got harvest time! Do I have a refrigerator yet?
No, I do not. Fine dining research, but that's coming next after sanitation
Oh, shit yeah!
But I think that'll be okay but tha-- Because that's gonna be enough to...
Oh yss. Oh Yiis give us all that. Oh hell yess.
Make ALL the meal lice (Unintelligible)  life.
Loaf Lices.
Leaf Leases.
Okay, There we go, Cool.
So now the water's gonna be kinda--- Uh oh.
Well Gabriel, you done- you done fucked yourself now.
Alright, How about you try to...
Try to get out over there first, yeah.
Go for it gabriel, sorry you were stuck!
Oh, Someone-- Vernon, Why are you stressed Vernon?
Oh, cause you're literally in the bullshit there. Okay.
So what we're gonna need...
Is we need... to run-- number one, run power through the floor. of uh, here.
So, power is gonna run through the floor...
Power is gonna follow down here...
And then we're gonna build a water pump down here...
Liquid pump...
Right at the base in there, probably...
Niegh probably there is good.
And we're gonna liquid pipe...
So that's pumping OUT. So that needs to pump into the IN, of THIS.
So I need to have a liquid bridge of some sort...
A liquid pipe bridge... And then this can go underneath it.
ya YA! THAT'S how you do it, ok.
and then the out is where the contaminated water is
So, then...
that can run...
Is that con... Ok, that can run over there.
To THAT pool.
But I'll need to be careful about that, because
It's gonna be...
That's gonna- again, that's gonna be...
contaminated area, so I need to
build an airlock.
A tile...
Need to re-tile THIS one eventually, but...
We'll get to that when we get to that.
Ok, so I just like the double airlock... you know, idea.
Just so it makes sure that no...
contaminated oxygen can slip through.
We got TONS and TONS of oxygen in here
This is pretty much saturated with oxygen.
We've got a good bit of algae left,
so we're going good there, we're...
we're running... we ran out of our first source of water.
I wanna make sure we don't run out of this one, too.
Um, I'll try to make an exchange here, as well,
but I don't see a Puft, but we'll get there
when we get there.
Once again, we'll get there when we-
this is- this, ALL this water is literally just for
showering and sanitation purposes only.
And once again, it's just Vernon that seems
to be stressed more than anybody else.
Alright, so that's mostly done...
So, this just needs power, now...
So, once this goes, is should go,
and then these should be running, correct?
And then we'll have...
Oh, no. They won't, because then they don't have an outpouring yet.
But they WILL.
So, what we're gonna do is after this, we're gonna
build a ladder DOWN.
And then it's, just going to be piping.
There, there, and there, there, and then it's just gonna literally
fall right there. OK!
And then that should be all that is needed.
Woo.
Ay, Ay, ok.
I'm actually kind of worried
because things seem to be going pretty well for me,
and they don't usually do that when I'm playing this game
so I'm a little bit CAUTIOUS of what's going on here.
Just don't wanna be too eager about nothing,
'til I get to where i need to get.
Ahhhh! Ohhhh!
Look at that, they can shower.
HOLY SHIT it worked,
oh my god.
But not yet, because they gotta get the outflows too, but
OH MAN, that works.
Holy shit
Yeah I just, I don't wanna back up
to k- to like, be in there
Ah shit, okay. Keep building that
stop letting so much contaminated oxygen in, okay?
Can you not do that?
Double airlock was supposed to prevent that thank you very much
Ok, you don't need to go through there anymore.
In fact I might make that other door-
Yeah I'm actually gonna do this.
We're gonna build this, and we're jus gonna get rid of that one.
But NOT until we've, built that one.
Not until we've built that one do you get rid of that one.
Just make them farther away from each other.
Alright, whatever, I guess we're gonna have a leak.
NO! Build the other airlock
God dammit, you sons of bitches.
You sons of bitches causing problems for me.
Is that what you're doing?
Just causing problems? huh?
You gonna be like that?
Okay stress is way down.
Vernon is still stressed, I don't know
Maybe he's just a whiny baby but.. uh
Stress seems to be way down
and I'm pretty happy about that.
I'm also pretty happy, the way that this is going
and uh.. you may have noticed that
I've been a little hesitant to go meet the people
that are a part of this but I just don't want to lose again.
Ya know?
I don't wanna feel like
I don't wanna feel like they're gone
So just let em
Hold them at an arm's length until I
I feel honored to be a part of them.
Ooo ready for harvest hell yea, buried muckroot!
Harvest that shit
Okay so we're gonna go over there hmm...
Jobs? Ohh.. they can have ooh
*laughing* I didn't, they can have specialized jobs?
Oh I didn't know that.
Ooohhhhh
Well I don't have anything I want them to do just right away but
I'm just gonna, ohh I could definitely specialize em later
God, definitely I could
Shit yeah!
Okay so what I'm gonna do is..
I'm going to
We're gonna, we're gonna build
Oh we don't have the extra power research that's right
Okay as soon as fine dining is done, we're gonna do more
yada yada yada
But this is, I mean this is fine for what it is
The pump isn't going all the time so
seems to be doing
just fine.. Okay research complete!
Aww, I thought that was the sound of the research being done.
Super computer gooOOoo, go super computer go.
*unintelligible noise* go super computer
Super computer can you go?
Please?
I still don't know if that is enough space in between the two of them
but I'm gonna, I'm just gonna ehhh...
I'm gonna risk it (X2)
Okay but anyway that was the sound of it.
Okay, so we need to make a refrigerator
is what we need to do for the food storage.
So we're gonna make a refrigerator up heeere.
Cause I wanted to run power up here anyway